hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that today you should
definitely watch with the lights on now
we welcome all genres of Cinema on this
here program and in episodes past we've
busted guts with comedy blown stuff away
with action and once I think we even had
a battle with rom-com superstars but
right now things are going to get scary
and go bump in the night and you might
possibly meet an underground version of
your own self kind of like Who I Am To
Toe for Grace oh my spider sense is
tingling today on versus it's a
hootenanny of heralded horror hellmers
who probably all liked Halloween because
we get Jordan peel taking on ariaster
against Robert Eggers you know Jordan
peel for being hilarious in the galaxy
of sketch comedy but more recently he's
directed Thrillers like get out and the
hotly anticipated nope in the next
corner it's Aster who loves nothing more
than a good wacky ritual depicted in
flicks like hereditary and mid-somar
then we have Eggers who's filmed the
witch puts him in Prime real estate on
the horror map before expanding to
luminous films like the Viking Epic the
northmen now the throne all here in
spirit of course I Mark Ellis pledged to
take you on a journey through their
filmmaking Odysseys still in progress to
see who Reigns Supreme as of right now
behind a camera the director has final
word on their set but now they're all
waiting in suspense for my judgment
which puts a lot of pressure on me I'm
really just saying words that will
hopefully celebrate their careers but it
might get competitive so if y'all want
to get crazy we can get crazy here's how
we'll determine a winner round one box
office round two Tomato Meter slash
audience score round three characters
round four ah and then we'll do a Wild
Card round that I hope won't involve
more screaming that one was pretty
mailed in I'll be honest Mike and Sully
would get no credit for that whale I
just ushered I guess I'm lucky that I've
never had to shriek and tear for that
long
foreign
in the hands of any one of these three
Master Craftsmen you got Jordan peel and
his penchant for Unique storytelling
Concepts Ari Astor's astounding and
terrifying visuals Robert Eggers
examination of historical mythology it's
just about every one of the movies we're
about to discuss I've seen in a packed
theater with tense audiences including
the time we all had to leave halfway
through because a real life earthquake
was happening you want to guess which
movie I'll tell you at the end in the
meantime we're about to chill some bones
and tingle some spines Let's Get It On
round one box off
clearly I'm not the only one willing to
Fork over some hard-earned cash to see
the films of Jordan peel ariaster and
Robert Eggers they've each made films
that have done well at the box office
often times on Tiny budgets and the
exciting part is that it feels like
they're just getting started meaning we
get to do an updated vid rematch in like
you want to do five years sounds good
every five years from now on
so far Robert Eggers has seen his star
on the rise thanks to his 2015 Sundance
premiered movie The Witch a film that
word of mouth its way to an impressive
40 million dollars on just a 4 million
dollar budget from there he would go on
to do the dark psychological comedy
the lighthouse which pulled in only 18
million dollars but still turned a nice
profit off of an 11 million dollar
budget then we got treated to the much
more expensive than northmen which has
grossed 65 million worldwide to date the
budget has been reported to be anywhere
from 60 to 90 million but regardless of
where that exact number rests that makes
this Viking Quest by far the most costly
of any film from our directorial Trio
today in fact the next priciest film us
cost 20 million dollars and after that
no one spent more than 10 million bucks
to make a feature with the obvious
exception of the lighthouse ariaster
appears to be the most frugal as
hereditary and midsummar combined for a
19 million dollar budget because someone
had to pay for those flights to Europe I
feel like I can't tell if you're joking
and both turned in a hearty return on
investment hereditary burned up the box
office to the tune of 81 million dollars
while its follow-up mid so Mark grossed
47 million so let's recap the score so
far Astor's total gross from two films
is 128 million dollars besting Robert
Eggers by Jess five million dollars but
Eggers had another movie to toss on the
pile so his average per film is
currently 41 million dollars while
Asters is 64 million bucks all right The
Gauntlet has been thrown down the high
bar has been set and good God that's
Jordan peele's music
dude is a force to be reckoned with at
the multiplex and he hit the ground
running with get out as the Smash Hit
generated 252 million dollars worldwide
on the big screen peels 2018 follow-up
us would surpass even that as it hauled
in 256 million dollars on that 20
million dollar budget if your gut is
feeling that Jordan Peele is going to
walk away winning this round here's some
quick math that confirms it his two
movies that we have complete earnings
for so far have totaled over 500 million
dollars making for a per flick average
of 254 million bucks would his third
film have helped yeah did he need it to
win this round nope it's the name of the
anyway no peel takes the first point of
the day and goes up one to nothing to
nothing you ain't seen that one coming
did you round two Tomato Meter slash
audience score
sure money is great and all but isn't it
also the root of all evil I guess that's
how you spend it well this round is
about who spent what seeing your picture
it's gonna come down to who had the
biggest smile on their face leaving the
theater or in the specific case of these
three shot callers who stirred up the
most nightmares later that evening
hahaha
peel continues his hot streak here with
the critics as get out earned a 98 on
the Tomato Meter which stands as The
Benchmark for any movie In Contention
today us also clearly pays attention in
school as it received the a grade of 93
are you kidding me the dude has a 95
average in the veggie garden Ari and
Bobby have their hands full in this
round as well and I shouldn't have
called him Bobby right I shouldn't have
called him Bobby stop it Mr Eggers does
ratchet up the competition in this round
as he's got three movies that all could
possibly get into an Ivy League wait
list the witch and the White House are
tied at 90 percent and the Northman is
just a shade off the pace at 89 that's
good for an
89.66 percent average and did you really
expect the number 666 did not make a
cameo in this episode thanks Beast
you're a great Iron Maiden tune please
take a nap
Astor steps up to the plate and while
his Tomato Meter output is the lowest of
the three he's still doing pretty well
hereditary's at 89 on the Tomato Meter
while midsomar is resting at 83 percent
so that's an 86 percent average which is
still somehow in last place the audience
scores the only hope for Esther now and
um there's freshness to be had it's
interesting usually with hard content in
decades past a movie would do okay with
critics but great with audiences who
love a good scare but here arya's work
dips into the 60s with the audience you
the good people of Earth have landed on
68 for hereditary and 63 percent for
midsomar which given to the content in
that film is a huge win all right so we
got some freshness here with a 65
percent average for Ari Here Comes
Robert Eggers good news the Northman is
at 63 percent fresh on the audience
score and the White House is at 72
percent all right it's time for the
witch to drop the Hammer with the 59
it's rotten according to the audience
how did y'all not appreciate that weird
looking Goat as far as creepy goats go
black Philip is the goat
that's going to hurt Eggers overall
average on this metric and so he dips to
64 and once again the door's been left
to jar for Jordan peel to come claim a
point and us is it just 60 what is
happening whoa whoa the critics are
slurping all this content the audiences
are getting a little more choosy but
even the choosiest of moms choose GIF
and the most selective of crowds still
approve of get out it's at 86 percent
here and all is starting to get restored
to normal peeling his averages 95
percent of the Tomato Meter and 73 on
the audience score are poised for
another handy Victory here but before we
call it around here's a fun fact every
one of the movies we're discussing today
are in the top 50 of the 100 best horror
movies of all time according to Rotten
Tomatoes you can check that list out at
the website the only flick appearing
here that's not on that list is the
Northman which isn't really a horror
movie not for the most part
that list of horrific greatness has the
movies in order of adjusted Tomato Meter
which is kind of like saber metrics for
baseball or next-gen stats for football
and that I don't understand them but I
respect them I know by the way according
to this very list the top two horror
movies of all time are get out and us
that is what you call putting an
exclamation point on the cake Jordan
peel hasn't lost around yet and now he's
up two to nothing to nothing that feels
wrong I don't like that round three
characters
so peel is looking for the first three
Pete and versus history although The
Simpsons might have done that first as
well in a round called characters you
always bet on the sketch comedy genius
so if we were allowed to bump in his
many hilarious roles birthed at either
Mad TV or key and peel it would be a
walk-off Grand Slam for sure but we're
only looking at the feature films these
fellas have directed so unfortunately
legendary Creations like Ty Royal
Smoochy Wallace disquarius green and D
Isaiah T Billings Clyde will not be
eligible in this round luckily for
Jordan characters inhabited by The
Talented Daniel kaluya can count he's
featured in the upcoming nope but at the
time of this taping your idiot host had
encrypted data into paying for him to
see the movie yet anyone interested you
call me hell no while I wait for that
star to arrive kaluya was a breakout
star thanks to the success of get out
where he played Chris Washington the
boyfriend of Rose Armitage inhabited by
Allison Williams whereas Rose does a
tremendous job of pulling the wool over
Chris's and the audience's eyes it was
kawuya who expertly handled his Chris's
slow realization that strange things are
afoot at the Armitage family compound
and by the end of the film all of that
simmering rage finally comes to a boil
and as the heads of the Armitage family
Bradley Whitford and Catherine Keener
make for such a creepy good team of
psychos that they're impossible to take
your eyes off of I'm also going to give
major points to Lil Rel howery for his
expert comedic timing and the role of
buddy Rod Williams I mean I told you not
to go in the house for us with Peter
Nyong'o Winston Duke and Company got to
play two roles a piece alongside
virtually everyone else in the world you
see while the upstairs team of Adelaide
and Gabriel are attempting a family
vacation the downstairs folk red and
Abraham went in on the fun in fact
nyongo doubled up on her already
meticulous prep to play the Dual role
practicing the voice of red for weeks
and taking ballet lessons for Adelaide
for Ari Astor's hereditary Tony Colette
was the perfect choice to play Annie
Colette is a self-described optimist so
for her the fear and Annie came from a
slow Awakening that this nagging feeling
you can't shake your whole life is valid
and all those pieces are starting to
come together but you know look on the
bright side as long as you can the
Graham family is rounded out with
Gabriel Byrne Alex Wolf and Millie
Shapiro who we will talk about in
another round very soon chill's just
thinking about it and if you thought the
trip to Wilson's took in US was scary
wait until you meet the travel agent for
Florence Pugh and Jack Rayner in
mid-somar the pair go to a retreat in a
European Countryside to observe a little
scene festival and it just goes so wrong
on so many levels as Christian Rayner
sees firsthand the price of toxic
masculinity might cause one to pay and
Florence Pugh's character Danny and her
slow unraveling makes for a gem of a
performance for Robert Eggers a
character round may not need to be one
with quantity just witness the expert
performances of Willem Dafoe and Robert
Pattinson in the lighthouse I hope you
enjoyed them because they're pretty much
the only two folks in that movie God
damn Fox
damn
God damn it Defoe can be so menacing and
unhinged yet we still want to trust him
and learn from him and yeah not get on
his bad side for Robert Pattinson it's
an examination of what it takes to
preserve one sanity and close quarters
and if you do go over the deep end can
you ever get back out of that pool the
witch also had a relatively small cast
it's really just a family and a witch
and a goat the latter of two might have
been in cahoots but in those portrayals
that film becomes tense and visceral as
Thomason Anya Taylor Joy was a
revelation and she later revealed that
the script freaked her out upon an
initial read she was taking it in late
at night and when she finished as she
was trying to process that ending she
all of a sudden felt the grip of fear
and anxiety now those are red flags that
you and me but for an artist of her
caliber that's now the feeling that she
claims to be chasing whenever she reads
a new script from now on to each their
own but the deciding factor in the
character round may be that sprawling
epic that costs the most money of any
film competing today in part because the
Northman has won a list cast you got
everyone from Alexander Skarsgard each
of his many abs Nicole Kidman Willem
Dafoe Anya Taylor Joy Ethan Hawke Bjork
for goodness sakes Eggers teamed up some
old casting faves with some new blood
all led by Alexander Skarsgard intense
physical prep to play am with a viking
hell bent on Revenge for most of his
life to get in shape for the role wait
wasn't he already ripped this dude that
played Tarzan right Alexander ate every
two to three hours took in about 3 700
calories a day and worked out at least
three hours a day so I can do at least
two of those things his spirit animals
were a wolf and a bear whereas mine is a
napping guinea pig under a water bottle
for all three epic Tales woven by Robert
Eggers featuring a bevy of memorable
performances it will be he who earns the
point here in round three and he just
got on the board Jordan Peele still
leads two to one to zero round four
my scream's just getting worse all right
usually around this time of the show as
you the loyal fans already know because
you watch each and every week whoa whoa
our day month I don't know our schedule
around here this would be when we talk
about the most iconic moments from a
particular film franchise performer or
in this case director but we're gonna
get specific today because we have
masters of horror on the playing surface
so this round will be won by who's
delivered the scariest freakiest
shockiest which is not a word but it
should be sequences Robert Eggers is hot
off of a big win in the character round
but did those roles lead to ghoulish
frights in the case of the witch that's
a hell yes emphasis on the helm
sorry
the film creeps and crawls along but
there's always a looming presence just
out of frame that keeps us on the edge
of our seat the entire time glimpses of
the older witch played by Bathsheba
Garnett give us a shriek all the while
the rest of the film is teasing us with
mythology causing our own psychological
Health to Teeter on the brink witnessing
a witch on the roof is always going to
get my goat as will literal goat Black
Phillip with that really freakish stare
the real goat that played Black Phillip
goes by the name Charlie and is
apparently a sweetheart shows up to set
on time never a problem but that
character yikes different story don't
talk to the cursed goat that was pretty
much the only parenting required in the
1600s so every time the kiddos venture
out to have a conference call with Phil
we all get a little nervous and why is
it always children's games that scare
the crap out of us in horror movies here
we get peek-a-boo and it's much more boo
than Peak but this is all preamble to
that epic finale when we see a ceremony
in the woods and a new recruit Thomason
showing off her Newfound abilities what
a horrifying satisfying ending to a tour
de force or exercise the witch is great
start to finish and wow does it
broomstick The Landing
the northmen even with its action tilt
will still give viewers chills I mean
come on Willem Dafoe still in it and the
visuals like the raid in the village
scene can certainly stay with audiences
long after the lights go up speaking of
Defoe his foray into madness in the
lighthouse tricks us into walking down
that path with them even when we're all
having a good time and hitting the sauce
a little too hard there's a scary look
waiting for us in the very next frame
and that mermaid sequence is um well
it's not where you're gonna find in The
Little Mermaid not the Disney one anyway
Jordan peels get out was able to spend
some serious social commentary into a
horror Thriller with a pinch of satire I
believe they've been abducting black
people
brain watching them making them work for
them as sex slaves and [ __ ] sorry about
thank goodness Rod is around for some
laughs we need him to offset truly
terrifying moments like when Chris is
trying to relate to some of the staff at
the armitage's compound they run very
specific routes in the middle of the
night and the closest they can get to
Warren and Chris is a stifled tear and
uttering no no no witnessing the sunken
place can make the audience feel like
we're trapped there as well and
originally Jordan Peele had an even
darker rating for the film in mind but
he went the more crowd-pleasing route
I'm gonna say that's the right call
especially knowing now what the next
film was going to be us is an acting
Clinic put on by Lupita Nyong'o and as
the tethered read every facial twitch
and tick is a tiny horror movie in and
of itself needing the tethered Focus
frightening enough seeing their power
and speed as they break into the house
makes me wish I had a panic room at my
place and every director needs a good
mirror scene on their resume us utilizes
a house of reflective surfaces to usher
in Surprise shock and chills and equal
doses it's a pretty much even scored
this moment between Jordan Peele and
Robert so now Ari Astor takes center
stage and I'll be honest every time I
hear that dude's name the first thing in
my head is those old people taking a
plummet in midsomar it's like what the
hell is going on and then I felt like I
was just stuck on this campus and
couldn't find my way out College paper
be damned I will drop out of school if
it means I'm catching the next flight
out of that place almost on par with
that moment is hereditary and you know
the scene I'm referring to don't stick
your head out the window humans that
trick is meant for dogs only they get
the wind blowing back their hair people
they tend to lose their head it's a bad
day for the grand family things would
only get worse as we see matriarch Tony
Collette doing everything she can to
preserve what's left of her wits that
one family dinner that you kind of want
to miss and speaking of decapitation and
he takes care of her own Noggin in a
violent sequence towards the end of the
movie what wins this round the most for
me in favor of Ari Astor is the
nightmare delivered to us courtesy of
Florence Pius Danny in mid-somar you
pair that with Jack randers comeuppance
and you got yourself a education that
we're never going to talk about again
all three directors will continue to
spell bonus with their unique
storytelling Styles but the Striking
visuals from Astor are permanently
lodged In My Memory Bank you can't unsee
that stuff so thanks for that reason he
gets his first point of the day and it's
the Sprint to the Finish as Jordan Peele
has two points astrone Eggers have won a
piece oh my God thank you man
that is incredible news thank you and
now it's time for the Wild Card round
cultural impact three young directors
just getting warmed up in Hollywood are
featured on today's show precocious
towns though they may be they've already
had a significant impact on the culture
surrounding not just horror movies but
all of entertainment and beyond for
Robert Eggers his greatest contribution
to Modern culture might be reminding us
from Once We Came stories like the witch
and the northmen hearken back to a time
when religion and mythology fueled our
belief systems and charted out the
course of The Human Experience pretty
much from birth to death and then
possibly the afterlife obviously there
are still those tenants that a good
number of people uses guiding lights in
their current lives but sing the
formation of belief in bygone centuries
does prove to be an alternate angle for
the modern Human Condition ariaster
shares some of the entomological passion
of his fellow competitors today and the
ritualistic nature of his films make us
question the logic of our own practices
now granted the rituals we see in a
movie like midsomar are hopefully more
extreme than anything you go through in
weekly basis but it still makes you
think right you're right I'm sorry
you're right Jordan Peel's movies have
used the framework of a thriller to tell
compelling modern day allegories
revolving around the injustices
perpetrated by humans to one another for
the last few centuries in get out it's
the rich white family and they're rich
white friends holding down black folks
by making them hostages in their own
minds in us we see a world where we're
all lucky to be on this surface is all
of humanity suppressing another twin set
of beings down below I really hope not
the cultural impact of Peel's work is
easiest to notice it's enhanced by
overwhelming critical and Commercial
Success of his features thus far at this
pace he'll continue to be not only one
of the most bankable directors in
Hollywood but also one of the most
important ones for his inaugural
directing effort get out he received an
Academy Award nomination in that
category and he also became the first
black person to win the Oscar for best
original screenplay and what I admire
about all three of these filmmakers is
their ability to tell an incredible
story with unparalleled vision tools on
a comparatively shoestring budget now
Robert Eggers recently proved he can
take a large sum of money and make the
scope of the tail large enough to
Encompass the entire known world that
was the Northman but you can also give
the dude a few million bones and you'll
get something equally as engaging Ari
Asters pension for images and scenes
that stick with us for weeks months
years to this day is one of his best
traits and it's why he'll always have a
willing audience show up even if we have
no clue what the subject matter is about
you know like with mid-somar but there's
something extra special about what
Jordan Peele is doing his movies have
transcended more boundaries as evidenced
by the worldwide box office take yet
they can still pack a powerful message
just below the surface the Oscar praise
has proved positive that he's beloved by
critics and his peers oh and also he
came from a sketch comedy background Mad
TV key and peel biting hard commentary
all three of those things kind of do
work together as all three of our
competitors today continue to influence
our present by informing us about our
past where we come from and where we're
going as of this moment in time the
queer winner in a round about cultural
impact is Jordan peel and that's his
third point and that's a win for peel
over Robert Eggers and Ari Astor a
well-played match across the board
[Music]
oh yeah good victory guys good victory
hey hey come on good game slap bad so a
few years ago a buddy and I went to the
ArcLight theater in Hollywood where I
live I mean I drove from the valley but
still we're in the movie and it's about
halfway through the picture and as tends
to happen sometimes in Southern
California the ground started shaking it
wasn't earthquake not a huge one but big
enough for all of us to get the hell out
of that theater and the movie was you
guessed it midsomar I remember the Quake
started shaking R4 right as those old
folks were soaring into the next life I
might not have even noticed the moving
ground at first because I was so
Spellbound by the visuals I was
witnessing Ari asked her his movies are
so captivating you won't care about the
natural disaster that's currently
occurring at the same time I can't wait
for the next Robert Eggers feature
either but today it's nope director
Jordan peel getting the win of course
this is all just my opinion and I spent
a good 20 minutes on the floor laughing
at all the names from that Monday Night
Football spoof on key and peel now it's
your turn to voice an opinion who's your
favorite director of the current Bunch
hit up your favorite host on social
media at Mark Ellis live and you get
tickets for upcoming stand-up shows at
markellis.live keep it tuned right here
to Rotten Tomatoes for all the latest
and greatest in the world of movies TV
and more for everyone here I'm Mark
Ellis thanks for watching versus and
remember kids don't talk to the cursing
code
[Music]